I spent the last six months hiding in
tekking's basement and researching one
piece Secrets day and night just so I
could bring you this video okay not
really but through my research for
dozens of other one-piece videos I came
across some absolutely wild secrets and
theories including stuff about the true
identity of Luffy's mom the dark truth
about imusama the real nature of the one
piece and more in this video I will be
sharing the wildest one-piece theories
that actually make sense when you think
about it fair warning it's gonna get
absolutely crazy in here and the last
theory in particular is the most
outrageous one piece Theory you will
ever hear I guarantee it and I'm willing
to bet that you've never heard this one
before if you enjoy the one piece
content on our Channel and you want to
see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment it helps us out a lot
and if you're one of the over 50 of
people who watch our videos regularly
but still haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a big favor and
subscribe right now finally this video
will contain one piece manga spoilers a
lot of these secrets and theories are
related to spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned okay
so even though the recent arcs of the
story have given us a lot of answers
that we've been searching for for years
like for example the true identity of Dr
vegapunk there are still quite a few
massive mysteries in the one piece world
and one of the biggest is the identity
and current status of Luffy's Mom some
believe that we've already met her in
the story we just don't realize it's her
While others think she's gonna be
introduced at a climactic point during
the final Arc of the story I'll be real
with you guys some of the most unhinged
fan theories center around Luffy's
mother but if you're expecting me to
talk about the theory that Luffy's mom
is actually gender-bent crocodile you're
wrong that's just way too popular and
mainstream right now that stuff is for
One Piece Theory virgins but this video
is for One Piece Theory Chad so let's
start it off with the theory that
Luffy's mother is actually a Celestial
Dragon and the reason why we still
haven't met her is because once the
other world Nobles found out about her
illicit relationship with Luffy's father
she was abducted and taken prisoner
somewhere in marijua as the theory goes
at some point Luffy's dad Monkey D
Dragon met and fell in love with a woman
from a family of celestial dragons we
know very little about dragon's early
life but we do know that GARP wanted
both his son and Grandson to become
Marines so it is possible that earlier
on in life dragon was actually a marine
and working for the world government if
that was the case then it's not crazy to
think that he came into contact with a
Celestial Dragon at some point during
his career the meeting could have taken
place anywhere but one possible scenario
is that Dragon met Luffy's mother on God
Valley maybe a young dragon was one of
the Marines fighting under garp's
command on God Valley and since we know
that multiple Celestial dragons and
their slaves were present there it's
possible that dragon and came into
contact with Luffy's mother as he was
saving her life from the Rocks Pirates
after meeting 38 years ago on God Valley
dragon and Luffy's mom were able to stay
in touch and carry on a relationship in
secret many years later Luffy is born
and after that his mother disappears
perhaps her secret affair with dragon
was discovered due to her pregnancy and
as soon as she gave birth she was
abducted by the world Nobles and
imprisoned as punishment for having a
relationship with a commoner this is why
we still haven't met Luffy's mother and
this is why both Luffy's dad and Grandpa
hate the celestial dragons so much and
why Dragon dedicated his entire life to
overthrowing them now of course God
Valley in particular may not be related
to Luffy's mother at all or even if it
is maybe Dragon actually saved one of
the slaves of the world Nobles and she
is Luffy's mom but Luffy's mother being
a Celestial Dragon would answer a lot of
questions we still have about dragon and
the DC Clan For example why is dragon in
particular known as the world's worst
criminal seemingly even worse than the
pirate king Goldie Roger well we know
the celestial dragons put a lot of
importance on their bloodline and on the
fact that they have the blood of the
creators of this world they see
themselves as Gods who are clearly
Superior to Common humans so much so
that many of them don't want to breathe
the same air as commoners Soul who would
be the absolute worst criminal to these
people it would be a commoner who had
the audacity to have a child with a
Celestial Dragon thereby proving that
the world Nobles are nothing special
since their blood can easily be mixed
with the blood of commoners by having a
child with a world Noble Monkey D Dragon
would have discredited the entire belief
system of the celestial dragons and to a
bunch of egomaniacs with a superiority
complex that is the worst crime
imaginable this could also explain the
mysterious secret about his past that
dragon has been keeping from everyone
including his own revolutionary comrades
I mean if your whole pitch is that we
gotta overthrow these evil and corrupt
Celestial dragons you're probably not
going to advertise the fact that you're
actually in love with one of them
finally this could explain that whole
thing about the D Clan being the natural
enemies of the celestial dragons because
think about it if Luffy ends up being
the one who overthrows the world
government at the end of one piece and
if his mother turns out to be a
Celestial Dragon then the fact that a
single World Noble chose to get together
with a single member of the D Clan led
directly to the destruction of the
Celestial Dragon now to be fair a lot of
people think that Luffy's mom is just
like dead and that she's never going to
play any role in the story so according
to them all of the speculation about
Luffy's mom is basically pointless but I
tend to think that if she really was
dead or I would have just made that
clear and that no one would have to be
distracted by all this pointless
speculation since she hasn't been
confirmed to be dead I believe that she
will make an appearance sometime before
the story ends and if she is an
imprisoned World Noble that would make
for a great reveal sometime during the
final battle it would be absolutely epic
to see either Luffy or his father or
both of them together Bringing Down the
world government and finally rescuing
Luffy's mother but if you think that the
theory about Luffy's mom being a
Celestial Dragon is crazy trust me it
only gets way crazier the next Theory
which is quite popular in the comments
of my one-piece Theory videos is that
not only is Luffy's Mom an important
World Noble but she is actually the most
important World Noble all the secret
ruler of the entire world imusama and my
own headcan and imusama is definitely a
woman with dummy mommy energy so this
Theory isn't as far-fetched to me as it
might seem to some people anyway let's
get back to God Valley we know that the
world Nobles who were present on that
island at the time of the incident were
not just any Celestial dragons they were
extremely important members of the world
government system we know that because
rocks wanted to overthrow the world
government and become the king of the
world and he chose to bet everything on
attacking God Valley we also know that
the world government was so desperate to
protect these specific Celestial dragons
that they were even willing to make an
alliance with the notorious pirate and
wanted criminal Goldie Roger something
that up to that point was completely
unprecedented so both the actions of
rocks and the actions of the world
government suggest that whoever was on
God Valley at the time was very
important we're talking either to
gorosei or even imusama and the way in
which the world government handled the
god Valley incident after it happened
may suggest that it really was imusama
who was there that day that's because
the world government did everything it
could to erase all traces of God Valley
and the god Valley incident from history
so much so that it is even dangerous for
high-ranking Marines to talk about it
let alone anyone else the world knows
about the gorosei so if they were the
ones who were threatened on God Valley
would we really need to erase every
trace of what happened from history the
one who decides which light is erased
from history is none other than imusama
and as the fate of the kingdom of La
Lucia demonstrates emu is extremely
committed to keeping his or her
existence a secret so the Celestial
Dragon who was on God Valley may have
been emu In the Flesh and she may have
also been the female World Noble That
Monkey D Dragon rescued and fell in love
with on that day that is certainly an
intriguing proposition but that seems to
raise more questions than it answers why
would somebody like emu fall in love
with a teenage marine and have a child
with him why would Dragon dedicate his
life to fighting the world government if
his beloved actually controls the entire
thing why would Luffy's mother approve
the assassination of her own son at the
hands of cp0 yeah imusama being Luffy's
mom would be a mind-blowing Twist if it
turned out to be true but it is just
incredibly unlikely thankfully there is
no shortage of crazy theories about
imusama's true identity and these next
ones are even more insane what if I told
you that rocks the zebic didn't actually
die on God Valley not only did he not
die he actually succeeded in achieving
his ultimate goal of becoming the king
of the world it's just that no one
realizes it yet that is because imusama
is actually rocks in the sky guys he
somehow managed to fake his own death on
God Valley and then proceeded to seize
control of the world government from the
Shadows after that he carefully erased
the god Valley incident from history in
order to hide the truth about his secret
rise to power Roger and GARP believed
that they defeated their old enemy rocks
back on God Valley but in reality their
old enemy is still alive and well and he
will be the final villain of the story
Blackbeard somehow found out the truth
and that he named his ship the saber of
zebic as a tribute to the king of the
world oh and did you know that imusama
uses a saber as well just like zebic
epic evidence unlocked Theory confirmed
okay not really but since we're already
on the topic of rocks there's also the
theory that rocks is actually Luffy's
other grandpa I did an entire video
talking about this but essentially the
theory states that Rox is either the
father of Luffy's mother and therefore
Luffy's other grandpa or Rox is actually
dragon's real father and that's why the
two of them seem to look alike in the
first scenario after rocks was killed on
God Valley GARP felt bad for his
daughters so he took her in like he
would later take Ace after he took her
in she fell in love with garb's son
dragon and the rest is history in the
second scenario GARP is not Luffy's
paternal grandfather but his maternal
grandfather the father of Luffy's mother
GARP may have met Dragon during the god
Valley incident when Dragon was a
teenager and then after rocks allegedly
died and his crew disbanded GARP felt
bad for rox's teenage son and took him
in Dragon then met garp's daughter the
two of them fell in love and the rest is
history it's an interesting Theory and
it connects Luffy to rocks in a really
unexpected way but even if this theory
was confirmed we still wouldn't know
what actually happened to Luffy's mother
personally I'm not too concerned about
whether GARP is Luffy's maternal or
paternal Grandpa I'm more concerned
about where Luffy's mother is right now
but okay no more Luffy's mom theories
well after this one last one you want to
hear a really unhinged Luffy's mom
Theory how about the theory that Luffy's
dad is actually his mom yes dragon's big
secret that he's hiding even from his
comrades is that he is actually a woman
but he asked ivankov to turn him into a
man in order to conceal his true
identity from the world government or I
guess to conceal her true identity I
mean that would be a pretty great way
for a wanted criminal to keep his
identity hit it but then again we're
left with the same problem if dragon is
Luffy's mom then who is Luffy's dad and
why does ivankov's devil fruit continue
to be the worst thing to ever happen to
one piece theorists we are now moving on
to another outlandish family-friendly
Theory the theory that Blackbeard and
kuzan might actually be brothers and
that they are both the sons of rocks the
zebic we all know that theory that
Blackbeard is the orphan son of zebik
Who Wants Revenge for what happened to
his father on God Valley but there is
also a theory that because Blackbeard
and kuzan share some physical
characteristics they may actually be
related they may even be brothers this
might explain why kuzan decided to join
the Blackbeard Pirates one of the most
shocking and baffling decisions in
recent one piece history personally I
think that kuzan is definitely a double
agent but some believe that he's just
backing his little bro Blackbeard and if
koozan turned out to be Blackbeard's
brother or even the son of zebic then we
would have yet another member of the
d-clan in our midst maybe that's why we
still don't know kuzan's full name
because his name is actually rocks D
kuzan or Marshall D kuzan this theory is
pretty wild but it's not even close to
what comes next I know I've talked about
imusama already but I really recently
saw a theory in the comment sections of
one of my one piece videos that I never
even heard of or thought of before the
comments suggests that emu could
actually be Shanks himself either Shanks
is leading a double life as a notorious
pirate and the king of the world or
Shanks has a split personality kind of
like Cavendish and hakuba either way the
idea is that Shanks knew full well what
the komogomanomi was and he's been
keeping a close eye on Luffy for a very
specific reason he is actually using
Luffy for his own ends and he may even
turn out to be the final villain of the
entire series while I appreciate how
insane this theory is I don't think it
holds any water we know that emu
destroyed the kingdom of La Lucia while
Shanks was traveling from wano to elbav
so he was definitely not in marijua at
the time there's also the theory that
mihawk is actually emu because of the
similarity of their eyes but I don't
give much Credence to that theory either
one crazy emu theory that I do like is
the theory that he or she may be
immortal and that this same person has
been ruling over the world ever since
the void Century we know that obtaining
immortality is possible within the world
of one piece with the help of the op up
fruit as long as its current user is
willing to sacrifice him or herself in
order to make someone else Immortal it's
definitely plausible that one of the
previous users sacrificed themselves in
order to make emu Immortal many
centuries ago and some even believe that
the gorosei may be immortal as well but
this immortality idea has been around
for a while so it's not even the
craziest emu Theory out there the
madness really comes into play with the
theory that imusama may actually be an
alien and that the ancient war from 800
years ago was none other than an alien
invasion of Earth what's that you say
who would be in insane enough to back a
theory like that well I'm glad you asked
because I just recently made an entire
video on it and I will link the video
down in the description if you want to
check it out I broke the theory down in
detail in that video but here I'll just
sum it up very quickly we know that in
the world of One Piece you can live in
space there was an entire ancient
civilization on the moon and even today
space pirates and anel live up there
unlike in our own world the outer space
in the world of One Piece appears to
have oxygen and gravity so it is
possible to travel through space just
like an L did with The Arc Maxim and
just like the moon civilization did when
they left the moon to resettle on earth
now that Globe from O'Hara showed us
that Beyond just the Earth and the moon
other planets and moons seem to exist in
that world so what if one of those other
planets or moons was home to an advanced
civilization that decided to invade made
Earth during the void Century emu was
their leader and he set up shop on top
of the red line after defeating and
overthrowing the former gods of the red
line the lunarians this space and alien
connection is also why the celestial
dragons call themselves Celestial
dragons and why they wear spacesuits emu
and the aliens didn't want the world to
know that they were foreigners who came
from another planet and then subjugated
everyone on this planet against their
will so they decided to erase the truth
and create an entirely new history in
order to keep the people in line they
Proclaim themselves to be gods of this
world usurping the title once held by
the lunarians and they erased every
mention of their true Origins from
history after all if the peoples of the
earth knew that they were being ruled
over by Alien Invaders who were
foreigners to this world then they would
be more likely to Rebel but if they
thought that they were being ruled over
by the rightful gods of this world then
they will be more more likely to obey
Joy boy and the ancient Kingdom were the
earthlings who fought to repel the Alien
Invasion during the void Century but
they failed and then they disappeared
from history maybe the real reason why
emu's face still hasn't been revealed is
the fact that emu clearly looks like an
alien and Oda doesn't want us to know
that quite yet in the full video I made
on this Theory I also went on to explain
why the one piece may actually be a
comet so if you're interested in
astronomical levels of crazy just check
out the video link in the description
but as insane as all of this stuff was
and it definitely was insane the
absolutely wildest Theory out there is
this next one which I actually came up
with myself now of course I haven't
scoured the entire internet so I can't
say that no one mentioned it before me
but I personally haven't seen it
anywhere else if by some chance you have
seen it somewhere else definitely drop
me a line below and let me know oh this
theory states that we the readers of the
One Piece manga are actually characters
in The One Piece story does that sound
crazy enough for you allow me to explain
Oda has spent a lot of time fleshing out
different aspects of the power system in
one piece including of course devil
fruits hockey technological weaponry and
so on but one ability that has remained
a gigantic lingering mystery is the
voice of all things an extremely rare
ability to communicate with living
creatures and inanimate objects
telepathically out of the over a
thousand characters in one piece there
are only five known confirmed hearers of
the voice of all things and there is
also a rumor that everyone in the
three-eyed tribe has the potential to
awaken this ability the voice of all
things seems to allow the hearer to
understand the deepest thoughts and
feelings of a creature or an object
however no one aside from the few chosen
hearers of the voice of all things is
able to detect the voice in any way
knowing Oda there's definitely going to
be a good explanation for the voice of
all things it's not going to be just a
random ability that exists and is never
explained this concept has been
mentioned again and again since early on
in the story and I think that it's
definitely going to play some important
role in the conclusion of the manga now
I can understand the ability for two
living sentient creatures to communicate
telepathically with each other I mean it
still needs to be explained how exactly
this works and why it happens only with
these specific individuals but I can
understand it what I can't understand is
the ability of inanimate objects with no
sentience to communicate telepathically
with living creatures I mean in Naruto
you can Infuse objects with chakra and
then other people can interact with that
chakra but that's not something that's
been established in one piece so why are
inanimate objects like pornoglyphs able
to interact on a telepathic level with
users of the voice of all things like
Roger when I was seven years old I read
a book that fascinated me and one part
of the story in particular was so
memorable and impactful that I remember
it to this day the book that I am
referring to is the never-ending Story
by Michael ended in one scene the main
character of the story is reading a
fantasy novel and as he is reading it he
suddenly realizes that the characters in
the book are actually talking about him
one of the characters says that the
reader of the fantasy book Bastion has
been sharing in all of their Adventures
by reading the book just like other
readers have been sharing in bastian's
own adventure by reading the very book
that I myself was now reading this was
such a crazy breaking of the fourth wall
for me as a seven-year-old and it stuck
with me forever so then the character
from the fantasy book calls out
bastian's name directly and as he's
reading the book he sees his own name
written on the pages of the very book
that he is reading eventually he enters
this same fantasy world that up to this
point he was only reading about so what
does this have to do with one piece well
the never-ending story was extremely
popular in the 1980s and it was
especially popular in two countries its
country of origin Germany and Japan this
means that Oda would almost certainly
have been exposed to the never-ending
story at some point before he wrote one
piece and I think that the voice of all
things may be directly inspired by this
book what if the voice of all things was
created by Joy boy using the power of
the Nika fruit the power of imagination
itself and what if the voice of all
things is a way for characters in the
story to connect to us the readers of
the One Piece manga think about it we
know all the characters because we've
been sharing their Adventures this
entire time we know about the poneglyphs
and all the other Mysteries that have
been revealed so far and by the time the
story ends we will know all the
Mysteries that are yet to be revealed so
what if tapping into the voice of all
things is like breaking the fourth wall
like tapping into the voice of the
readers and all the knowledge that they
have and that they will have in the
future the voice of all things
transcends time and worlds and it places
us into the one piece story albeit in a
more indirect way than Bastion in the
never-ending story Roger can hear the
voice of the pornoglyphs because we the
readers will eventually learn the truth
about all the pornoglyphs and because
the voice of all things transcends time
and worlds something that we will know
in our own world in the future can be
accessed by Roger in his world in the
past in that way all of us continuing to
read one piece and share the Journey of
its characters is what helps to
literally sustain that world and so all
of us the readers are literally part of
the one-piece world now do I think this
theory is actually true no I think it's
way too out there but it is the single
craziest theory that I was able to come
up with can you guys think of even
crazier theories that still kind of make
sense leave your thoughts and theories
down in the comments I'd love to hear
from you my favorite insane Theory from
the comments will get pinned if you guys
enjoyed this crazy one piece video leave
a quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps me with that YouTube
algorithm and if you're one of the over
50 of people who watch our videos but
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a big big favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications subscribing is completely
free on YouTube It Only Takes a second
but it helps a lot you can also hit me
up on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys